ماذا ان قامت الحرب فعلا عشرون سيناريو
قدمها مركز الدراسات الاستراتيجيه الدوليه
لكن السيناريو الاكثر احتمالا للحدود هو
بدايه الغزو بقصف صيني يدمر معظم البحريه
التايوانيه وقواتها الجويه ويفسح الطريق
لغزو برمائي بكين ستطوق تايوان وتمنع عنها
اي محاولات لايصال السفن والطائرات
وهنا ياتي دور واشنطن تسليح تايوان
بالكامل لكن قبل الحرب هذا الامر سيقلل من
تاثير الضربات الصينيه الاولى وسيجبر
الصينيين على الانتشار اكثر على طول
الساحل استخدام الولايات المتحده لقواعدها
في اليابان امر ضروري اخر مثل الوحده
البحريه التي تم تحديثها اخيرا والموجوده
في اوكيناوا تضم اكثر من 25 الف عسكريا
امريكي واكثر من 20 منشاه اختياره وتحديدا
جاء لانها قريبه من تايوان تبعد اقل من 70
ميلا من تايوان اذا السيناريو الصيني في
هذه الحاله سيكون حربا شاملا هجوم سريع
وعبور مضيق تايوان بغطاء جوي قصف صاروخي
وهجمات بالمقاتلات واللجوء للحرب
الالكترونيه بالطبع لكن ما نتيجه كل هذا
كارثه على الجميع اذا انتصر تحالف واشنطن
فلنصر سيكون مكلفا جدا على المدى الطويل
البحريه الامريكيه ستفقد حاملتي طائرات
على الاقل في المحيط الهادئ وهي اصلا
تمتلك احدى عشرات الخدمه وسيتدهور الجيش
التايواني بشده سيقتل 3200 جندي في ثلاثه
اسابيع من القتال يعني تقريبا نصف ما
خسرته الولايات المتحده في عقدين من
القتال في العراق وافغانستان الكارثه ستحل
ايضا بالصين فبح ستدمر ستخسر اكثر من 130
سفينه كبيره ومئه وخمسه وخمسين طائره
مقاتله كما سيقتل حوالي عشره الاف جندي
وماذا عن تايوان شبه جزيره مدمره بالكامل
ومستقبل قاتل